we caught up Tom Steyer in a tiny town
of Mayflower Arkansas where he was
getting a look at the cleanup site from
an estimated five thousand barrel oil
spill here is some just off the top of
the water it's sticking it's extremely
sticky know very soon it smells awful
steyr had come to mayflower to gather
ammunition for what may be the biggest
fight of his life trying to stop the
Keystone XL pipeline from being built it
would stretch from the Canadian tar
sands across the u.s. to refineries on
the Gulf it's not going to the United
States what the true argument is that
it's going to be more oil not from the
Middle East that is true but it doesn't
mean it's more oil to the United States
not formula it just means there's more
oil not from the Middle East in the
world market even after an accident like
the one in Mayflower decedent Keystone
could be a long shot for steyr I think
that this is a topic on which people eh
don't really understand what it is and
be it's always presented as either we do
this or we do nothing that's absolutely
not true we're not going to run this
society with that energy it's just a
question of how we think about it but
Keystone is just part of the problem
steyr says the bigger climate issue is
how the tar sands oil is recovered from
the Canadian tundra this is a gigantic
mining operation in the middle of
nowhere they want to take production by
2025 more than double it and your job is
to make sure that never comes out of the
ground well look if not from my point of
view I'm not a scientist the scientists
say it would be devastatingly terrible
for the 7 billion people on the earth if
it does
you